hola
os acordáis del año 92 el año 92 para
españa fue un año muy importante fue el
año del ave fue el año de la expo de
sevilla fue el año de los juegos
olímpicos de barcelona yo recuerdo
nítidamente donde estaba en el 92 en el
estaba aquí en la politécnica aquí al
lado y acababa de empezar primero de
carrera a todos studies calculando
humedad
y en el 92 cayó en mis manos un artículo
científico que hablaba de dos cosas
aparentemente dis conexas el artículo
hablaba de el cerebro y la informática
cosas que aparentemente están totalmente
desconexión y el artículo hablaba
prometía un concepto inquietante
redes neuronales que aprenden de la
experiencia
lo cual se postulaba como uno de los
santos griales de la informática como
una de las promesas y vamos a ver por
qué en la informática si tú quieres
resolver un problema típicamente tienes
que tener en cuenta todos los casos
posibles y programar para que tu
programa responda de una manera de otra
pero hay problemas que nos pueden
parecer muy sencillos y resulta muy
difícil codificar los de esta manera
esto que os he contado a los
informáticos a los ingenieros nos gusta
llamarlo algoritmo lo habréis oído
alguna vez algoritmo pues bien hay
muchos muchos problemas que nos parecen
muy sencillos para los cuales es muy
difícil hacer un algoritmo y vamos a ver
un ejemplo
un ejemplo tan sencillo como diferenciar
un perro de un gato
verdad que parece fácil entonces vamos a
hacer un juego y vamos a intentar hacer
un algoritmo viendo las fotos del perro
y el gato habríamos capaces de enseñar
un algoritmo viendo la foto del perro
podéis pensar bueno los perros tienen
orejas redondas con lo cual el algoritmo
si ve que tiene orejas redondas pues va
a ser un perro oye y los gatos tiene
orejas puntiagudas
ya tenemos algoritmo no pues bueno no
tan rápido porque enseguida va a
aparecer un perro con las orejas
puntiagudas y un gato con orejas
redondas y así va a pasar si nos fijamos
en el hocico en la piel en las garras
etcétera vale por eso es tan sumamente
difícil hacer algoritmos para problemas
que aparentemente son tan sencillos como
clasificar un perro de un gato
así que yo estaba en el 92 con toda la
energía de un alumno de primero de
carrera que yo mis manos el artículo veo
un problema complicadísimo que es
clasificar una imagen un perro y un gato
y me puse a programar yo recuerdo que me
puse a programar como un loco por las
noches aquel a que aquel red neuronal
que se supone que aprendía de la
experiencia aprendía viendo fotografías
de perros y gatos como hacemos las
personas según el santo grial de la
informática una promesa hasta entonces
incumplida
y bueno me puse a programar y aquello no
funcionaba
estuve noches y noches que a fin algún
día llegaban los exámenes y dejé de
programar
tenía que probar
y no solo yo había muchos más
investigadores que en esa época
experimentaron con redes neuronales
resolvieron el problema del aprendizaje
con la experiencia
de este modo pasó el tiempo
y los ingenieros los programadores nos
dedicamos a resolver problemas más
accesibles con algoritmos ya habían
algunos problemas intocables como la
clasificación de imágenes que no
tocábamos
sin embargo mientras pasaba el tiempo
estaban ocurriendo dos revoluciones
delante nuestra que la mayoría no nos
dimos cuenta y la primera revolución que
ocurrió vino de donde uno menos se lo
espera vino de los videojuegos
los videojuegos que tendrá que ver los
videojuegos con el cerebro
pues resulta que los videojuegos en tres
dimensiones utilizan una operación
matemática que ofrece recordaréis de las
matemáticas de antes de la universidad
que es la multiplicación de matrices
muchos les tomarías manía pues sirven
para jugar
pues bien la multiplicación de matrices
es una operación clave para las redes
neuronales clave y a medida que los
videojuegos aumentan en calidad aumentan
en prestaciones
a medida que ocurre eso aumenta la
capacidad posible de cómputo cada vez
más barata esa fue la primera revolución
la segunda revolución que ocurrió en el
2007 ocurrió gracias a otra cosa está un
poco aparentemente inconexas a los
teléfonos móviles al iphone en el 2007
salió el primer iphone que hacíamos con
los iphones quizás más que llamar por
teléfono a hacer fotos no paramos de
hacer fotos que las ponemos en internet
no paramos de hacer fotos que ponemos
internet y que pueden ser etiquetadas
fotos que sirven potencialmente para
entrenar redes neuronales
y tanto es así que en el 2012 una
competición internacional del problema
que os he puesto al principio de
clasificar imagen es más complicado que
perros y gatos
hay que clasificar una imagen en mil
categorías
y sabéis quién ganó en el 2012 no la
gente que utiliza algoritmos
convencionales de si la oreja es así
hago una cosa o si el hocico es así hago
otra no gano un equipo que utilizo redes
neuronales entrenadas con imágenes
sacadas de internet
utilizando tarjetas gráficas de
videojuegos aquí podéis ver el primer
equipo es el que tiene la barra más
pequeña el error como vaporizó los
resultados
en clasificación de imágenes en este
equipo
fue el que dio el pistoletazo de salida
de la inteligencia artificial lo que hoy
en día aunque la inteligencia difícil ya
existía hoy en día realmente estamos
escuchando mucho de la inteligencia
inicial y en verdad viene motivado por
las redes neuronales gracias a la
capacidad de cálculo
motivada por los videojuegos y a las
grandes cantidades de imágenes sacadas
de internet desde entonces las redes
neuronales han superado ya a la
capacidad humana en detección de
imágenes sirven al colectivo en medicina
para ayudar al diagnóstico e incluso
para el diseño de enfermedades y hay un
campo que también es muy interesante y
es el de la condición autónoma
la condición autónoma promete un santo
grial también que es mejorar la
seguridad las carreteras entre otras
cosas cada año mueren un millón de más
de un millón de personas en las
carreteras todos los años y tanto es así
que al ser un problema no resuelto
muchas empresas
crean desafíos competiciones como la que
en su día ocurrió en el 2012 para ver si
la comunidad científica ayuda yo me
sentía de alguna manera en deuda con mis
desde el año desde el año 92 con las
redes neuronales y vi que alibaba una de
las empresas punteras de china y como
sabéis china es un país puntero e
inteligente artificial
había convocado una competición para la
conducción autónoma una competición de
inteligente artificial aplicar la
producción autónoma entonces me intenté
volví cogido a la energía de mis 17 años
y me apunté a intentar apuntar a la
competición pero fijaos lo que pasó me
voy al formulario para apuntarme y os
decía que estaría todo el mundo pero me
pidiendo un teléfono chino
tengo un teléfono chino ahora - suena
coronavirus no
y bueno les escribí oye por favor
de apuntarme eso
españa me interesa mucho la competición
y ya estaba a punto en twitter escribir
en twitter
sólo puede ser quejarme sabía que si me
quejaba ya nunca más podía entrar en
china
no se puede descargar antes de darle al
botón pero antes de darle el botón
vuelve a chequear el formulario y mirar
admitiendo españa
conseguí medir españa
con chino
[Aplausos]
bueno eso es lo fácil lo difícil que es
competir
la competición era muy complicada
consiste en detectar obstáculos de
condición real en china que eso es una
locura también mucha gente tiene carne
la gente no lo sabe
y bueno y que utilice algoritmos
convencionales no utilice redes
neuronales utilizando datos de internet
con tarjetas gráficas y junto con mi
compañero
pavel que lo conocí haciendo
competiciones nos quedamos los primeros
a nivel mundial en china y no solamente
nos dieron un premio nos dieron dos
premios
en esta competición por la mejor
solución que es un tema objetivo y la
solución más ingeniosa de toda la
competición
y bueno podemos pensar que ya está
que ya hemos conseguido el santo grial
de las redes neuronales que aprenden de
la experiencia pero bueno ahora que ya
tenemos ese santo grial esa promesa
cumplida yo miro adelante y quiero ver
que ahora tenemos que exigirnos
sistemas de inteligencia artificial más
precisos sistemas de inteligencia
artificial más éticos que no tengan
sesgos por ejemplo sistemas de
inteligencia artificial que en
definitiva sean más humanos
miro atrás miro al año 92 y quiero que
veáis
el nombre del investigador que escribió
el artículo geoffrey hinton ahí tener su
foto en el 92
miro atrás mira el 2012 mirar los
nombres de los investigadores
geoffrey hinton el mismo
20 años
espero este investigador geoffrey hinton
para lograr su sueño de redes neuronales
que aprenden de la experiencia
y quiero terminar
recordándome a mí en año 92 con la
frustración de no haber podido entrar a
la regional
casi 30 años después me veo aquí
en el tx habiendo logrado después del
mundo tiempo entrenar una racional
inspirado por investigadores como joffré
hilton y muchísimos más y quiero pedir
un aplauso para todos los investigadores
que nos inspiran
[Aplausos]